Rebecca was this the first time you'd
heard of Christine Chubbuck story yes I
had no idea about Christine Chadwick
I've never heard about her the first
time that I heard of her or or why she
is at all well known and it marginally
well-known really it was when I got the
script with a cover letter that had a
set of five lines synopsis of what the
film was about I understand you had some
footage like 15 minutes or so yeah I was
about 15 20 minutes about she was 15 it
was 15 I think I'm yeah of interviewing
a segment of her morning show which is
really all that's out there and it was
quite you know a dried piece of photo
she's interviewing someone so this
subject takes up most of the air and
it's about a zoning board petition in
Sarasota it's not the most thrilling
better material but it was you know in
the in the 70s often they'd shoot things
in one static wide shot so I was able to
watch her all the way through and watch
her responses in her body language and
her and you know you can it sounds like
a short amount of stuff to to go on but
actually you can into it an awful lot
about someone from the first meeting as
we know and if and often those
intuitions are quite powerful so if so
that the building of the character felt
like an exercise in letting that
intuition work on this bit of footage
and building it from there and what was
your take of her I mean you asked me
what my take of her was that's that's a
slightly confusing question because my
takeover had to be what was the script
you know it was it was really theirs
Craig Schiller which his take of her and
then there's me interpreting the writing
so a lot of though everything I get is
from is from the script it's how the
dramaturg
decides to draft the story what story he
wants to tell so I don't know I think he
wrote something profoundly compassionate
and there grapples with someone who is a
Multi multi strand lead and complicated
and difficult and and does something
truly frightening and tries to grab
with that in a compassionate way and
humanized that person well we often hear
that actors don't judge their characters
so that being said did you feel any
scene with tremendous empathy more so
than of course the obvious where they're
certain let's say the puppet show where
she was almost speaking to herself in a
sense she was talking to these children
but it was almost as if she was
self-medicating in some sense no that
scene was very much a way to show I
suppose what was going on on the inside
a little bit I suppose the way one of
the ways in for me was that I found it
fascinating that she seemed to me to be
someone who was terrified constantly
that she was getting it wrong that she
was judged that her version of herself
that she paradoxically only wanted to be
herself and refused to be anything else
but there was also this deep-rooted fear
that it wasn't accepted that it wouldn't
work so I always thought that there was
an element of her that was performing
what she perceived to be normal and
sometimes she's quite good at it and
sometimes it's bad acting like it's
actually bad acting and you see it and
you see them you see the what's going on
in the inside versus the thing that
she's trying to convince everyone that
she's good at and that and there's the
sort of gestures and the kind of sense
of someone in control felt to me almost
like a politic when a politician does
that sort of studied thing of I know how
to be this person that's in control of
everything and that to me was a key I
suppose because I think there are a lot
of I think there are a lot of portrayals
at people who are misfits and Outsiders
that somehow in some way glamorize it
and kind of make it look like it's cool
or it's incitive that the sort of other
nurse is interesting and I think this is
a film that dares to show how painful it
is to feel that you are other
indifferent and what a struggle that is
when you can't be anything about that
and the difference is that you get being
done that when you're a woman in the
seventies workplace versus a man I
suppose not Mary Tyler Moore yeah you're
not Mary Tyler Moore exactly